um welcome everyone and uh lina thank
you very much uh for the uh the nice
introduction uh my name is eric burkell
and i'm the founder and ceo of rpod
diagnostics
and uh today i would like to talk about
how a comprehensive pharmacogenetics
accelerates personalized therapies and
can reduce health and disparities
for diverse populations
health disparities and among ethnic
groups in the u.s
you know it is well recognized that um
for racial and ethnic minorities in the
u.s health disparities really take on
obviously many forms including high
rates of chronic disease premature death
and um and that's compared to like other
races for example like
whites and caucasians we obviously
recognize that
the causes of health disparities are
complex they're socio-economic factors
which play a role but if we're thinking
about
you know other factors genetic variation
is really now recognized that this also
plays an important role
in the disease development and if we're
thinking about
then treating diseases obviously the
variation in the response to treatment
the drug response
exemplified by pharmacokinetics as well
as pharmacodynamics
can explain part of this variability
among diverse
populations
so we recognize in general as we're
thinking about pharmacogenetics that the
response of patients
is not uniform so we see clearly a
variability
that is really common knowledge i mean
clinical practice
not every drug works for every patient
and that relates not only to efficacy
but that also relates to the the
prevalence and the occurrence for
example of side effects
and the toxicity the goal of
pharmacogenetics
is to really provide actionable data to
provide a
safe and more effective pharmacotherapy
through the application of the genetic
information and
obviously then guide also if we're
thinking about drug development of
identifying new drugs
guide drug discoveries and therapeutic
decisions
when we're thinking about applications
of pharmacogenetics there are a number
of different areas where
this is currently applied at various
levels
obviously in clinical research as we try
to better understand the variability
of drug response so to expand our
knowledge base
there's also the component of obviously
establishing clinical utility of
pharmacogenetics in the application
in that area another area where um and
this is really growing
is the application of pharmacogenetics
in the area of drug discovery
and there are you know obviously plenty
of examples with the advancement of
precision medicine now
that drugs now um the treatment of a
drug or the selection of a drug gets
particularly treated
uh get linked to a genetic makeup of
a patient um and the goals for that is
that it obviously reduces the length
time of and the complexity of the drug
development process
and in drug discovery we're thinking
about going in clinical trials
pharmacogenetics is applied in early as
well as late day at stage clinical
trials
and we're thinking about clinical trials
we can think about the concept of
pre-emptive
or reactive pharmacogenetic testing
where we do the testing before a patient
gets exposed
to a drug or gets a drug prescribed but
we also can think about the other
concept is the more reactive
pharmacogenetic testing
where a patient receives a
pharmacogenetic test
after for example we observe toxicity or
after we see a therapeutic failure or
the occurrence of adverse events um in
many cases then obviously
the results are not necessarily in a
clinical research setting
returned to patients
um if we're thinking about um you know
and asks the question how frequent
um or what's the prevalence of where
pharmacogenetics could be applied
i want to show you some results from a
review
paper published now about five years ago
uh when we're looking at the the
prevalence of how many drugs are
currently on the market
where there are clear guidelines for
pharmacogenetic testing
overall there are about 300 actionable
genetic variants
which are linked to dosing guidelines
and fda approved drugs and um currently
there are about a thousand two and
actually more than thousand two hundred
drugs currently
fda approved and seven percent of these
drugs have clearly
pharmacogenetic actionably results now
you can look obviously at
the overall medication but the probably
more interesting way to look at this is
as not every drug gets frequently
prescribed and there's variation in
prescribing patterns
you can look and ask the question so of
how many of the prescriptions filled
in a in a year in the u.s how many of
these drugs and prescriptions which are
failed have actionable pharmacogenes
and that's about 18 so if we're thinking
that about four billion prescriptions
are
filled in the u.s 18 actually presents a
substantial
uh number of drugs in patients actually
receiving these drugs
so that really speaks to the to the
overall applicability and
also the the great potential utility
of pharmacogenetic testing
when we're thinking now about genetic
testing and you know we started out with
that we we wanted to expand this
uh to diverse populations um
one thing we need to recognize that this
is um actually a phenomenon
um common to genetics research in
general
and has been recognized just very
recently is that
most of the genetic studies and studies
which are performed to identify
genes for diseases but as well as you
know for pharmacogenetics
these studies really have been performed
only in in europeans or caucasians
and ethnic minorities have really been
historically hundred percent
underrepresented in clinical trials
um so if you think about you know for
example in 2011
african americans in the us here
comprise about 12
of the us population but really only
participate
uh the participants we only see about
five percent
of them participating in in clinical
trials and on the right side you can see
kind of a breakup of the distribution
the ethnic distribution what we
what we normally normally see and that
causes and that directs us to
a number of concepts where i would like
to explain you and walk you through
to explain why i we think that very
comprehensive pharmacogenetic testing
which is not only focused on the
information where we obtain
and the frequency of variants which we
are mainly seeing caucasians
is really critical and we really need to
expand
in this area so so one of the things
which has been
recognized quite early on now
is that the allele frequency or the
variance
of star alleles differ between
ethnic groups quite significantly and so
just to briefly explain star alleles um
in genes and pharmaceums we analyze
many different dna variants these dna
variants are not necessarily independent
of each other they travel together they
are linked to each other
and so you can identify subgroups
uh you can identify subgroups of dna
variants and group them then together
in what we call haplotypes or star
alleles so
as we're looking for example at a number
of very commonly
genotyped or tested analyzed genes
relevant to pharmacogenetics for example
cyp2c19 cyp26
or coip2c9 you can see in the different
colors
the frequency of these different star
alleles in different ethnic groups
so for example if you look at cyp26
you see that some of these dialects are
pretty frequent in
in one population for example star 4
and they're not that frequent in other
ethnic groups and so and that has
actually been implications
uh for for pharmacogenetic testing
um and for example if we look at cyp2c9
to give you an example
star 8 and star 11 are genotyped in
panels
and really have been shown to improve
the warfarin dose prediction
um those uh the required dose for
anticoagulation
particularly in african americans
so um to give you an example of the
importance of
of uh testing of rare alleles again you
know
thinking about for example uh warfarin
because c1 has been linked to the
response to warfarin
and the required dose to to reach a
certain level of anticoagulation in
patients who require that
there's a certain variant which provides
great contribution to the variability in
dose
among europeans and that's obviously has
a higher contribution
in europeans compared to non-europeans
and that is largely explained
by the difference in the frequency of
this variant
this particular variant similarly for
star 5 haplotypes star 6 8 and 11
are identified in african americans but
essentially are absent
in non-african african populations
in addition to that there were just
there was a genomic association study
published
which uh identified a noble variant for
a particular
snip and a warfarin clearance in african
americans
but not in european or asians so what
that really shows
is that these allele frequencies and
also the presence of certain variants
which are unique to ethnic groups
are of significant clinical importance
um so i want to show you some example
and i want to dive a little bit into
a complex gene where we we again can
show
that um the the difference in allele
frequencies and
the frequency and haplotypes the
complexity
you know has really um important
implications for the selection of
oxidant farmer in pharmacogenetics
so i want to talk about a a one of the
most commonly
tested genes for pharmacogenetics that
is a cyp2d6
it's involved in the metabolism of about
25
of all clinically used drugs it is a
highly polymorphic
gene with right now over 114 distinct
groups of variants 113 star alleles
helpful types
what complicates that and you can see
this on the on the right side
on the the top example the gene
cyp26 lives right next to a
pseudogene cyp2d7 which
is also highly homologous so these genes
are very similar in their dna sequence
and cyp2d7 is a pseudogene now
pseudogenes do not get
transcribed they basically are just part
of the genome
and presumably do not have any any
function but
adds to the complexity now of analyzing
2d6 is that as you can see on the right
side
there are complex structural structural
variations in this gene
for example duplications we can have
deletions
and what makes it even more complicated
for the analysis that coip2d6 and 2d7
can
merge together parts of the gene can
merge together and form
so-called hybrid alleles so
that really uh provides great challenges
for the dnl a dna analysis as
we try to genotype this particularly
clinically important gene so i want to
talk a little bit about the
efforts of of analyzing
not only the common variants for 2d6 but
also the
the rare variance and i want to draw
attention to an initiative
which is really based at the cdc it's
called the genetic testing reference
material
coordination program a long name and the
abbreviation is get
rm and get rm's goal is really to
provide
reference material dna samples cell
lines
for interesting groups um and but also
characterize these samples with
all commonly available uh clinical
testing platforms and now in particular
here for pharmacogenics
uh so at rprd we were one of the
partners and
and participate in this reference dna
sample characterization project
and we provided the data using thermo
fisher's pharmacoscan platform
and analyzed about 179 dna samples um
and what we could show here and the data
is publicly available and we
would be happy to also share the link
for anybody who's interested
we actually found this using this essay
we found rare alleles um not only
in cyp286 which have not been described
um in uh other genotyping platforms or
were not detected in other genotyping
platforms because
uh some other platforms are not testing
really these rare variants
this platform also allows for the
detection of duplication and deletions
uh without the need for any additional
secondary methodology like
add-on tests for example to detect
duplications
and the platform also allows for the
analysis of these what i described to
you
complex structural rearrangements
between cyp 2d627
and we're very proud that the cdc
recognized
this project with the shepherd award for
leverage or design
science um just uh this year and below
you can see a link to the publication if
you're really interested in that
and the dna samples are available uh for
purchase you know if any labs are
interested in obtaining them
to use them as a reference material and
the clinical with the genotyping results
and all these platforms
are also available for download so i
want to show you one
and talk about one example where um
you know we participated by genotyping a
a sample and this was a case report
just published in genetics of medicine
together with our
collaborators at st jude's children's
research hospital
so this was a 18 year old male
african-american
who was enrolled in the pigeon for kids
preemptive
pharmacogenetic clinical trial which
is a trial genotyping clinical trial
genotyping all
patients who are seen at st juice
children's research hospital for
for clinical care in particular for
pediatric cancer
so we genotyped this particular patient
with
the dmet platform and that dmail
platform which is the previous platform
for
pharmaco scan and we detected for 2d6
a genotype or a diploid type of either
star 4 star 40
which would make this a patient
individual
a poor metabolizer meaning that this
enzyme has very little activity
um or if we detect it or we could not
conclusively determine it could also
have been a star
10 and a star 40 which would have
translated an immediate metabolizer
now the difference between a poor
metabolizer and a medium metabolize is
clearly highly relevant
because obviously this affects the
dosing of many
many potential drugs and this the
question for this particular patient was
related to the um the use of organ llgs
which are metabolized through cyp26
and obviously um the
correct dosing um for for this class of
drugs is really important to
prevent or you know reduce
adverse events um the disablement was
tested because we couldn't and that with
this whole platform could not
uh detect um a a
unique metabolizer status was sent out
to a different lab
and this lab tested and the report came
back as a star for star 17.
which would have translated this to a
a intermediate metabolizer and
so that was the
diagnosis at that time now we started um
because this was the previous platform
we
now started to genotype we genotyped
this sample
at rpid uh using the latest pharmaco
scan estate
and we actually in fact confirmed that
this patient was a star for star 40
poor metabolizer and i told you
cyp26 is a highly complex gene
and so just to dive into we
started to dissect you know the
differences in the different genotyping
platforms
so the star 40 haplotype really differs
from the star
17 haplotype by the presence of an
in-frame insertion variant
a particular insertion variant and if
this variant is not
probed then um what most of the testing
platforms do
will default to the call of a star 17.
and as we we mentioned um
in the previous slide you know these
significant these differences are
clinically significant and obviously
variant
important and relevant because the star
17 has an activity score of 0.5
while the star 40 has an activity score
of zero so there is no enzyme activity
so um the other important piece of
information
um which is to keep in mind is the star
40 in cyp26
is really commonly observed in african
americans in about a frequency over by
0.17 so while this is not really very
frequent
at this variant nevertheless it is
clinically highly
significant and relevant to dissect
even a look even at rare variants
in if you're particularly if you're
analyzing a non-caucasian
populations so most institutions
implement cyp26 genotyping
and they might not include this variant
and therefore have
the chance or the risk of you know
potentially
assigning a inaccurate phenotype
with that example i think we wanted to
show that
comprehensive coverage not only for
common variants and common
snips and it is really
important that we really very
comprehensively analyze
all pharmacogenetic potentially
important variants especially if you're
looking
if you want to you know apply
pharmaceutical testing to diverse
populations
um so allele frequencies of z now
vary between different ethnic groups and
again as i said i can be subject the
subject can be
you know at risk for misclassification
if a particular rare allele
is not included in a test and i just
wanted to
emphasize again uh some of the fda's
recommendation that the selection of
genetic markers
needs to be appropriate for the
population being studied and
should include also rare functional
alleles in the analysis
in addition to translating the genotypes
then into the relevant drug
metabolizing phenotypes so this really
emphasizes underscores our approach
to not only test common variants not
only test variants which have been
identified
in the populations which are frequently
studied but really
include also rare variants um
and make sure that you're testing in a
broad-based and
set of markers which are relevant uh to
a broad set of populations i just want
to highlight a few
uh things about this array the
array itself includes about 2000
relevant pharmaco
genes in about 150 genes covering
as i said diverse populations is
obviously fully
configurable it does a single essay
offering
both copy number as well as hla analysis
and depending on the genotypes you can
translate this there's software
available which translate this
into star alleles and if you're
interested in clinical research then
there are partnerships
with uh for example coryell and life
science and other
vendors who you know can guide and use
this information
for medication management reports so it
has broad applications
because it really includes
pretty much all pharmacogenes you can
think of right now all the acne status
genes
all the genes for pharmgkb level one and
two so it has broad applications across
many therapeutic areas for example in
cardiology
psychiatry neurology pain management
and also perioperative markers so it's
broadly based
not only targeted to a particular
disease area and as i said it's very
comprehensive the coverage
includes also all the markers which have
been recently
approved and recommended by the centers
of medicare and medicaid services
as a psychiatry panel it also includes
dutch ptx
pgx passport and includes if you're
thinking of different platforms
the catalog of the open array tag
panels so
in terms of application we see a
a great use and the ability to
use this platform for pre-emptive
screening in
targeted pharmaco for target
pharmacogenetic content
um as a high throughput and low cost
solution um so if you're just a little
bit more
now extension on pharmacofocus here the
content
about 88 of these variants reference to
cp guidelines with high level of
confidence
it uh includes copy number calling for
high value genes for example
uh cyp duty 2d6 where i told you about
the
the
copy number variations we observed but
also cyp 2 a6
gst m1 2 ugt 2b 17
and sult181 it also allows for hla
genotyping
of 11 loci and again
includes the coverage for markers found
in the the open array panel
and what's particularly i showed you the
example for
the difficult genotype 2d6 gene applies
to other genes
and again it translates this to about
880 star alleles
across the genes so if star alleles are
available
for a particular gene starling
nomenclature translates that
as well and is the platform itself is
available for 96
and i mean also in a 384 while format
for high throughput analysis
we did a comparison between the
pharmacofocus platform
and the pharmaco scan platform and just
to show you some examples
across the board we see over 99.8
uh concordance between these calls
between the different platforms
um same translates to it is on the
genotyping level
and if you look at the star allele level
for the genes where we have star alleles
we see a
very high concordance uh between the two
genotyping plus
a platform showing the uh great
comparability between
between those uh two tests um
the other thing what we at rpid offer
now together with
genotyping these platforms um is we have
over 18 close to 20 years experience in
translational genomic research
we provide in-depth analysis and custom
interpretations
and internet consulting for particularly
for
for pharmaceutical customers customers
in the drug development process
where we help and consult our
pre-clinical studies study design
for early phase clinical trials late
phase trials as well as
post marketing and you know we
contribute to answer some of these
questions like you know the
interpretation of
variation in in pharmacokinetics the
genetic analysis for the inter
individual variability in drug
response if you observe this in a
clinical trial
the genetic analysis for the lack of
efficacy for example
or the occurrence of adverse events or
toxicity what you see
the other approach what you can look as
obviously you can
try to enrich um your study for
responders in late phase clinical trials
using genetic information i think this
is an approach
which in the future actually will gain
quite significant interest or already
have the hassam interstitial will
really expand um we are a
clia certified pharmacogenetic
diagnostic testing laboratory and where
our team offers a full spectrum of
pharmacogenetic services
that includes pharmacogenetics high
throughput scan and custom panel
analysis
as i mentioned pharmacoscan
pharmacofocus
are platforms we offer in addition to
next-generation sequencing
as well as targeted sequencing analysis
using for example the the ampliseq
platform
we provide in-depth data analysis and
custom clinical interpretations and
as i mentioned already we're also
providing consulting services
for the pharmaceutical industry related
to clinical trials
and planned research projects we're very
innovation driven and we provide these
solutions
in a world-class scientific research
environment
we've been really bringing preemptive
pharmacogenetics into clinical use the
value of
preemptive testing is that if patients
have
genetic information pharmacogenetic
information is already at hand
you can use this information right when
you want to prescribe and a physician
wants to prescribe a drug
doesn't have to wait order a test until
then wait until the results coming back
so having preemptive pharmacogenetic
information available
before you know you have to make a
prescribing decision that has
significant clinical workflow
implications
so we've been piloting this with a
number of our customers and
collaborators now for
for many years and uh we're
demonstrating the value of this
um and we really offer high quality
pharmacogenetic testing in this
environment
uh by uh many healthcare systems
here in the u.s rely on our services
um so taking together i hope i could
show you um some of the um offerings
what rpid brings
to the scientific and clinical community
and the key points what i wanted to
emphasize
again is that obviously i hope i could
show you that the lack of diversity in
genetic research and clinical trials
may explain part of the ethnic health
disparities we have in the u.s
um it's a well-known fact that allele
frequencies differ
among different ethnic groups and we
really need to keep that in mind
not only for clinical testing but also
for clinical research
and as we generate more pharmacogenetic
information
we really need to keep that in mind and
recruit
minority populations in our in our
research
programs the discovery of many ethnic
specific alleles
shows the importance of comprehensive
elderly coverage
in pharmacogenetic testing especially if
you're testing
diverse populations and the pharmacoscan
and the pharmacofocus platform
provides comprehensive allelic coverage
which is an important consideration when
you're investigating and testing
diverse populations here in the us and
abroad
pharmacofocus as they demonstrate a high
level of concordance between pharmacos
to the pharmacoscan essay and rpd
as a team we have nearly 20 years of
experience and pioneering translational
genomics research and so we continue to
provide in-depth genetic analysis
interpretation
to guide clinical trial design and
improve the discovery process
so with that thank you very much for
your attention
and we will have some questions